[Music]
of course Billy is very funny stand-up
comedian listen did you ever try
stand-up here you're very naturally
funny but I don't know if you tried
standing I tried I don't you know I did
stand-up for like you know eight months
if even so it's like compared to what he
does it doesn't really count and I don't
know that it was skilled that I didn't
know you were supposed to bright no I
took all the things you're supposed that
part I believe yeah I'm just like I
guess I'll just have a shot and get up
on stage that's what they do right is
nice though the art well I think that
was kind of why I got out of it it's a
tough it's a tough room there's a lot I
mean I it's like any place you went to
it was almost like the same guy was
always in each club and I'm not kidding
as you did you were just placing your
foot on the stage so somebody from the
back of the room was always like show us
your boobs like they don't know what I'm
trying I'm like I'm in a wig and crazy
platform shoes I'm like oh come on
so now you've just been your first four
minutes just trying to make that guy
look like a a dingbat because he yelled
some but like every club I went to but
then I got downtown dude the duplex in
New York sure that place I love cuz it
was like a whole lovely gay boys and so
they never they didn't want to see boobs
don't show us your bones
silly stories wanted to see my boob
[Applause]